okay we're gonna go through multiple
examples I'm going to show you some of
the different techniques that you're
going to use just solve these equations
and some of the questions are a little
bit easier some are gonna be a little
bit more challenging let's jump into
number one here we've got 1/3 to the X
power equals 243 what you want to try to
do first of all see if you can get the
bases on both sides of the equations to
be the same so what I recognize here is
that 243 is really like three to the
fifth power and I recognize that 1/3 is
3 to the negative 1 power okay because
that's the reciprocal and remember when
you have a power to a power what do you
do to the exponents you multiply them
and so now you can see we have the same
base this is what's called the
one-to-one property of exponents you can
just set the powers or the exponents
here equal to one another so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say negative
x equals five multiply both sides by
negative one so you can see x equals
negative five and that's your final
result okay let's go to number two so
this is a log equation we have natural
log of X minus natural log of 7 equals
zero what I'm gonna do on this one is
I'm going to add natural log of 7 to get
it to the other side of the equation so
we have natural log of X add this over
so we get natural log of 7 and now what
this is called is the one-to-one
property of logs so as long as the bases
are the same which natural log these are
both base e then what we can do is we
can set these arguments equal to one
another and we have x equals seven now
one thing you want to pay attention to
is that when you get your answer when
you're solving these log equations you
want to just put it back in and make
sure that you're not taking the log or
the natural log of a negative quantity
or zero so this whole thing here should
be positive
otherwise it's extraneous so for number
three how would you do this one log base
5 of x equals negative two well an
important skill that you want to master
is knowing how to switch from the Log
form to the exponential form and vice
versa so the way I like to do this is I
like to think of as logs and exponential
functions as inverses of one another so
if I'm taking the log base five what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to exponentiate
meaning I'm gonna raise both sides using
base five okay and so now you can see
these are inverses so they cancel one
another out kind of like squaring and
square
or adding and subtracting they're
opposites okay so they cancel each other
five squared is 25 but because it's a
negative two we're going to take the
reciprocal so that's 1 over 25 and
that's our final result now remember
what I mentioned about logs you want to
take that and put it back in
yeah we're not taking the log of you
know a negative or zero quantity so that
means this is perfectly good so for
number four we've got e to the ax equals
seven so here what we want to do is
because that variables in the exponent
position is we want to bring it down
from there
by doing the inverse okay of
exponentiating we want to take the log
or the natural log of both sides of this
equation so I'm just going to write
natural log natural log I'm doing it to
both sides to keep it balanced remember
natural log is really like log base E
these are inverses of one another so
they cancel each other out and you have
x equals natural log of seven that's
your final result okay for number five
this one okay what we want to do is we
want to work from the outside in towards
this variable X we're trying to get the
variable by itself
so instead of multiplying by four let's
divide both sides by four okay and now
we have three to the x equals 16 we
can't get the bases the same here okay
because three to what power is 16 but
what we want to do is we want to say
well what's the opposite of
exponentiating let's take the logarithm
we just want to make sure that these
bases are the same so I'm going to take
a log base three of this side and log
base three of the other side to keep it
balanced right so these are inverses and
so we have x equals log base 3 of 16
this is an exact answer now if your
calculator doesn't allow you to change
the base okay what you can do is you can
use the change of base formula which
looks like this log base 10 you can pick
any base like natural log log base five
but here on most calculators you have
log base 10 or the common log 16 goes in
the numerator 3 goes in the denominator
so it's easy to remember because the 3
is a little bit lower right 16 a little
bit higher that's an easy way to
remember it that's your change of base
these are equivalent you can get a
decimal approximation on your calculator
for number 6 we want to solve for X here
so again like this one we want to work
from the outside in
towards that variable so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to add 12 to both
sides so that's going to give us 7 to
the x equals 40 well we can't get the
base is the same okay like we did in
that first problem but what we can do is
we can say well that variables in the
exponent position so let's go ahead and
do the inverse so let's take the log
base 7 of both sides right so those are
inverses or opposites and you can see we
just end up with x equals log base 7 of
40 if you want to use the change of base
formula we can do that here I'll use the
natural logs for this one natural log of
40 over natural log of 7 put this in
your calculator and get a decimal
approximation okay we're getting a
little bit more challenging here now
number seven we've got e to the 2x minus
e to the X minus 12 equals zero so the
technique you want to use on this
particular problem is to factor into two
binomials so here we can see eetu the x
times e to the x equals e to the 2x
because remember when you multiply you
add the exponents so x plus x equals 2x
and here we say what multiplies to
negative 12 but adds to negative 1
that's going to be negative 4 and
positive 3 and you can see that negative
4 e to the x and positive 3 to the e to
the x equals the middle term which is
negative 1 e to the X now that we have
it factored we can set each of these
factors equal to 0 so we have e to the X
minus 4 equals 0 and e to the X plus 3
equals 0 if we add 4 to both sides we
have e to the x equals 4 and if we
subtract 3 from both sides we have e to
the x equals negative 3 now what I'm
going to do because that variable is in
the exponent position I'm going to do
the inverse I'm going to take the log or
the natural log in this case of both
sides remember natural log is log base E
so these are inverses so we get x equals
natural log of 4 here if we take the
natural log of both sides these are
inverses so we get x equals natural log
of negative 3 but remember we talked
about earlier you can't take the log or
natural log of a negative quantity so
this is extraneous we're just going to
cross that out it's just going to be
natural log of 4 ok for number eight
what do you think for this one a little
bit more challenging what I would
probably do on this one is think of this
as
4/1 and when you have a fraction equal
to a fraction or a ratio equal to ratio
this forms of proportion and you can
cross multiply on the diagonal so 4
times 1 plus e to the 3x I'm going to
distribute the 4 so that's going to be 4
plus 4 e to the 3x equals 100 times 1
which is a hundred let's subtract 4 from
both sides so that's 4 e to the 3x
equals 96 let's divide both sides by 4
so e to the 3x equals let's see what
would that be 24 okay good and then we
just have to do the inverse now instead
of exponentiating we're going to take
the log of both sides or in this case
the natural log because this is base e
those are inverses and we have 3x equals
natural log of 24 divide both sides by 3
or you could multiply both sides by 1/3
to get X by itself so that's 1/3 natural
log of 24 and you got it now if you want
to get a little bit fancy you could
bring up this 1/3 as a power that's the
power property of logs and remember the
1/3 is like the cube root so another
option here would be to write this as
natural log of cube root of 24 okay for
number 9 we have a little simpler 1
natural log of x equals negative 5
remember this is a understood to be base
e so what we're gonna do is we're going
to do the inverse of natural log which
is to exponentiate both sides using base
E so these are inverses we get X by
itself so we have x equals e to the
negative 5th or because this is a
negative exponent we can take the
reciprocal and write this as 1 over e to
the positive 5 and that's your final
result there for number 10 a little bit
more challenging we've got log base 2 of
X plus log base 2 of X minus 2 equals 3
what I'm going to do on this problem is
use our condensing properties to
condense this into one log so what we
have is log base 2 of x times X minus 2
which comes out to x squared minus 2x
equals 3 so remember when you add you
multiply now what we're going to do is
we're going to do the inverse of log
base 2 which is to exponentiate both
sides of the equation using base two
these are
versus so that gives us x squared minus
2x equals 2 cubed which is 2 times 2
times 2 which is 8 let's get everything
on one side of the equation by
subtracting 8 from both sides so that's
x squared minus 2x minus 8 equals 0 and
now we're going to factor and set the
factors to 0 so what multiplies to
negative 8 but adds to negative 2 that's
negative 4 and positive 2 and then all
we have to do is set each group equal to
0 so we have X minus 4 equals 0 and X
plus 2 equals 0 add 4 to both sides and
subtract 2 from both sides now remember
when you solve these log equations you
want to make sure that you're not
getting any extraneous roots so let's
take take this negative 2 if we put
negative 2 back in we can't take the log
of a negative quantity that means that
this is extraneous across that one out
how about 4 well this would be positive
this will be positive so perfect so it's
just going to be x equals 4 okay we've
got a couple more examples here number
11 a little bit more challenging here
what I'm going to do is again I'm gonna
use the condensing properties for logs
and remember when you subtract what do
you do to the arguments you remember you
divide them right so remember we're just
combining these into one natural log
equals natural log of X so here what we
have we have log base E log base E we
can set the arguments equal to each
other this is called a one-to-one
property of logs so we're just left now
with X plus 3 over X minus 1 equals X
you can think of X as x over 1 because
anything divided by 1 is itself and what
we'll do is we'll cross multiply on the
diagonal using that means Extremes
property and x squared minus X so we're
just multiplying here you wanna make
sure you distribute the X let's get
everything on one side so I'm going to
subtract X and subtract 3 from both
sides so that's going to give us 0
equals x squared minus 2x minus 3 all we
have to do now is factor and set the
factors equal to 0 so this factors to X
minus 3 and X plus 1 if we set these
factors to 0 we get 3 or negative 1 now
let's look at negative 1 negative 1 what
would make
this negative this would also make this
negative we can't take the log or
natural log of a negative quantity so
this is extraneous let's double check
the 3 this would be 6 that's positive
that's good 3 minus 1 is 2 that's
positive that's good and over there it's
also positive so it looks like it's just
going to be 3 okay final questions see
if you can do this one here we're trying
to get of course X by itself thinking
about working from the outside in
towards that variable what's the
opposite of multiplying by 5
of course dividing by 5 right and so
that's going to come out to two and we
have log and we don't see the base so
when the bases are written it's
understood to be base 10 so I'll just
pencil that in for us and now because
that variables like inside of that log
we want to get it by itself or isolate
it by doing the inverse so instead of a
log base 10 unless exponentiate both
sides using base 10 those are inverses
we have X minus 2 equals 10 square which
is ten times ten or a hundred add two to
both sides and you can see X comes out
to 102 quickly go ahead and put it back
in make sure you're taking the log of a
positive quantity and that is so that's
our final result if you want to learn
more about logarithms follow me over to
that video right there where I go into
rewriting logs in exponential form
solving logarithmic equations graphing
logs follow me over there we'll dig into
some logs